everyone we are here at gamescom 2015
and danny has just played gears of war
Ultimate Edition is it the ultimate
edition of Gears of War Danny gears of
more stuff that gears of tomorrow
Michael for me I went out and you make
yours war I remember leave a game which
men came out what is it 2007 that's
something like that what a place I made
it co-op to co-op missions what a night
time one at a time and want to play it
is a pretty good remake appears of war
that I will be picking up so let's talk
about technical stuff right so all 60
frames per second it's all 1080
including multiplayer which i think is
actually the first time 60 frames per
seconds Benedict Gears of War II from
second in mohali players well singapore
key yeah and they've got land support
which is like a grown ice touch because
apparently people still do that
apparently people still fake Gears of
War One online I don't know and it's
it's the type they have like this
laundry list of features and stuff that
is adding to like they tweaked it the
quorum mechanics because gears warned if
you go back and place that is funky now
yeah they've got the like
omnidirectional goals and the kind of
slice to cover and I kind of feel so
they're more familiar to yeah exactly
and they've like fig split screen up
abyss they're just like nickel and tweak
to the bunch of like there's a whole new
chapter in the series after you enter
like Marcus's like picking around the
mansion the house before you met ram
apparently there's a whole like four
levels that happen in there yeah those
are the pc ones i think you're right Mac
you find a broom a kid all that stuff's
been put in as well all the cutscenes
have been re like Moe capped in the
world 1080 that the voice the audio
stops been changed as well it's all like
higher fidelity so I play two levels
doing co-op remember co-op I do remember
it fondly yep so you just like picking
up grenades chucking them people and
their use your fancy oh yeah and hit
next to revive and we actually didn't
need to get revived once that's a pro we
r who although right at the end I i did
a sticky grenade in someone and killed
both of us out right that's the only way
to go out in the game universe
drop the mic drop the mic on yourself
and explode I just it felt because yeah
they're good I think it reminded me of
like how good xbox 360 hot cakes or guys
another thing that the great thing about
the gears Ultimate Edition is there's a
lot of rerelease is coming out and for a
game like kids it would have been easy
to just up the resolution make it a
little cleaner crisper for what they're
trying to do is I mean I was reading up
about it and I think it's rod fergusson
said we want to make it upgrade it to
the point where it reflects how you your
nostalgia for it yes so instead of going
back and being like oh this is actually
not great yeah they want it then when
you put the disc in and you play it they
want you to be like yes this is exactly
how I remember yeah actually they've
done a whole lot of work yeah to make it
look like how you remember it just looks
better that's kind of I respect that
ethos and I respect I'm glad they're
doing that they're putting in the work
oh yeah also like the fact that you can
just slip back into it and it still
feels good it's a testament to how good
that core gameplay is and yeah they say
that people are still playing it because
it still feels amazing I haven't picked
up a gig a min like probably couple
years now at this stage judgment I
didn't take was very good at all and but
I was instantly like you slide shoulders
sliding at the cover and whatnot and I
think the idea of making like a new you
know re-release ultimate edition of
gears of war is about the most stupid
thing I can ever think of but I think if
you're going to do is they basically
like they seem to have nailed it they've
added all the condoms there they
scrubbed it off they kept all the weird
technical idiosyncratic things like land
play in there update is the split screen
but my most important thing about this
game is that it is not a full-price game
that is true keep perfect yeah it's that
in the current charge full price well I
don't know they can do whatever the hell
they want exactly i mean it was within
within their image to be like it's a
trend that began when I than I haven't
done it yes and the other thing that's
really cool about it is from either it's
now or whenever the game comes out up
until December 31st if you buy this game
you're going to get all the old ones
like all the Apostles yeah so you know
like gears one you got up the trick
we're doing through even the one you
don't want you don't want that one
that's an S or five games
for the price of power forward no I've
got very fond memories of playing gears
of war is the first Xbox game 360 game
that I got really upset with yeah like
one wrote rainbow six rainbow vegas but
yeah I got really sucks i'm looking
forward to maybe rekindling some of that
that love for the for the multiplayer
and playing through a single player
again whet the appetite for cues for
coming out absolutely next year so there
you have our opinions on Gears of War
medician for more on the games we've
seen at gamescom 2015 keep your eyes on
gamespot